now at their core background and
workbench jobs are very similar in that
they allow you to run scripts in a
separate session
this is a great feature for any long
running scripts you may have including
for example a machine learning training
step
it also allows you to run multiple jobs
simultaneously
now the main difference between
background jobs and workbench jobs is
that background jobs run as a child
process within the same session
and workbench jobs run as a new session
either on the local server or off host
if you're running in a multi-server or
clustered environment
so to demonstrate these two jobs I'm
going to first open up the currently
running rstudio session you see right
here on posit workbench
and in the top left corner you'll see
you'll see an R script called long
running script
in this script I'm first loading some R
packages so we're loading the Tidy verse
and then I create three variables X Y
and Z and I assign them the numeric
values 1 2 and 3. now I did this on
purpose so we can see how environment
variables work within background and
workbench jobs
each variable assignment is also
separated by a call to the CIS sleep
function which simply counts to 10 to
replicate a long running analysis
then I also have some code here at the
bottom which will write the Mt cars data
set as an RDS file to my current working
directory
so let's first run this as a background
job which will again run as a child R
process in the same rstudio session
to do this I'll select the background
jobs right here
and we'll select start background job
so I'll next ensure that the long
running script is selected so you can
select browse and I'll select that long
running script exactly what you see over
here
and then I can choose the working
directory and I'll just leave it as this
current working directory
next you'll see the environment option
now if I click this box
then anything I currently have in my
global environment which you can see
over here is empty would be made
available to the long running script
and finally we get to dictate what
happens to the results of the long
running script
so if for example we want to access
those three variables we created X Y and
Z then we'll need to select to global
environment
we also have the option to not copy the
results or copy them as a separate
results object
so let's select two global environment
and start this job
while it's running we'll get some
updates here in the background jobs tab
now if I try to close this rstudio
session we're going to get a warrant
here saying that essentially this will
terminate that background job if I close
this session so we don't want to do that
we'll hit cancel
and while this is running you can still
see I have access to my console here to
write some R code
so let's just give this a few more
seconds to finish up
and there we go we can see the three
variables we have copied to our global
environment x y and z
and the Mt cars data set is now in my
working directory
now let's demonstrate workbench jobs
which will again run in a separate R
session again either on my local server
or off host depending on how you have
workbench configured
so let me first delete the empty cars
data set right here
and I'm going to restart my R session
so let's first click on workbench jobs
and we'll select start workbench job and
you can see I've been playing around
with a few options here so I'll select
start workbench job
and we get the same two options we want
to select the r script we want to run
so I'll go to Long running script
and we'll select my working directory
and we'll do the same directory that
script lives Within
and then you'll also see up here
workbench job options
this allows you to choose things like
how much CPU you want to allocate to
this job how much memory and also
depending on how workbench is configured
you can also create customized Docker
images to deploy this job Within
so once you're happy with this setup we
can go ahead and start this job
now because it's running in a separate R
session we could actually close out of
this our studio session
and if we do that you can see in the top
right corner you can actually see the
long running script is running as a
workbench job
so let's actually open up that same art
studio session we were just in
so we'll click into it here
and if we go back to workbench jobs
you can see it's almost done running it
has finally succeeded if I refresh my
working directory we can now see the Mt
cars data set is now in my directory
now finally it's worth noting that you
can also run workbench jobs from within
vs code on posit workbench 2. so if I go
back to the posit workbench homepage
you can see I have this vs code session
opened up so I can click on this
and here we have that same long running
R script we showed before and on the
left hand side you'll see workbench jobs
and so if we wanted to submit a
workbench job through vs code we just
have to click this little plus icon
and just like before you'd select your
script working directory and you can
start this job
and hopefully this was a helpful
overview of both background jobs and
workbench jobs within posit workbench